[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
successor show that will air in 2022 on
hbo
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as show runners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood vol
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that
iconic seat all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart
the man who started it all king aegon
the first targaryen known as aegon the
conqueror
and aegon the dragon was the founder and
the first king of the targaryen dynasty
which lasted for 300 years when he
conquered all of westeros
and united the realm with the exception
of dorne and the lands beyond the wall
the two sister wives and their three
great dragons
valerian vegard and marxis aegon's
dragon was balerion the black dread
the largest dragon ever seen in westeros
balerion's jaws were so large
that he could swallow a mammoth aegon
was a child of house targaryen
dwelling on the island of dragonstone in
the narrow sea
the targaryens of family of valyrian
origin
had been in control of dragonstone for a
century before the doom of valyria
destroyed their homeland in a volcanic
cataclysm
for another hundred years on dragonstone
the targaryens slowly built up their
strength
and raised their dragons the last in the
world aegon was born on dragonstone in
27 bc
the lord aryan targaryen and lady velena
valerian
all of the previous six generations of
targaryens born on dragonstone were the
product of incestuous marriages
batarian had no sisters although by
marrying gabilarian he still ensured
that his children were of pure valyrian
descent
he had an older sister visenya and the
younger sister rhaenys
according to targaryen and valyrian
tradition aegon married within the
family
however instead of taking only one
sister to wife as had been common
he'd married both of them aegon was tall
broad-shouldered and powerful in
appearance
with purple eyes and shortcut silver
gold hair
he was very charismatic and commanding
during his conquest he typically wore a
shirt of black scales into battle
and will did valyrian steel sword
blackfyre his crown was a simple circlet
of valyrian steel
set with big square cut rubies aegon
fathered two sons with his sister wives
his older son aenes was born to rainey
since 7ac
and in 12ac visenya bore his younger son
maegor
later known as meg or the crew but back
to aegon's early days
the first major event in his life was
helping and the attempt by volantis to
conquer the other three cities
using his dragon to support the forces
of braavos tyrosh and the westerosi
storm king
in driving the volunteens from lees and
mir
in doing so he confirmed that he had no
interest in reforging a valyrian empire
in essos
aegon then began planning the invasion
of westeros long before launching the
attack
spending time incognito visiting
westerosi's cities and castles
and gaining intelligence on different
houses their lords and their vessels
he was helped in the planning by his
half-brother born out of headlock
or is baratheon his most loyal ally in
vessel
his best friend and the first hand of
the king when the king of the stormlands
air galactic arrogant offered aegon an
alliance against hair in the black
offering his daughter's hand in marriage
to cement the deal
aegon declined and instead offered
orisa's hand in marriage
argilac took that as an insult and cut
off the hands of fagon zenmoy
aegon used this as a justification for
his invasion of westeros
aegon his two sister wives and their
three dragons led a scanned few thousand
troops in invading the entire continent
of westeros
aegon fortified his initial landing
point at the northern shore of the mouth
of the blackwater river
strategically very defensible position
protected to the east and south by water
and surrounded by open plains which
would expose any attacking army long
before it arrived
shortly after landing his sister wife
wizenya crowned him king of all westeros
and shield of his people titles he later
discarded after his second coronation in
old town
despite being vastly outnumbered aegon
was able to secure victory after victory
using his dragons
the targaryen siblings departed to
aegonfort we take on marching northwest
into the riverlands to confront
harrenhar edmontale lured the river
undeclared for aegon
and led the river lords in revolt
against the rolling ironborn
when heron refused to yield harehole
aegon attacked a gigantic newcastle with
valerian
and household was extinguished with the
burning of harehole
the next day aegon named edmund as lord
paramount of the trident
meanwhile reigning senoris defeated the
randoms in the last storm
while visenya fought the arrests and
secured the cracklot point
after re-gathering at stone except the
targaryen siblings advanced against the
larger host of the two kings
king mirn gardner of the reach and king
loren lannister of the rock
the targaryen dragons valerian miraxis
and vogar allowed the aegon
to achieve a great victory at the field
of fire which resulted in the death of
mern the ninth gardener
and the surrender of lauren the first
lannister aegon then marched for
highgarden
where he named harlan tyrell as lord
paramount after the castle surrender
the targaryens again reunited to face
the host of torrence stark
the king in the north but tauren chose
to kneel to aegon
along the trident instead of fighting a
battle and sacrificing dozens of
thousands
of north men for the lost cons visenya
returned to the vale
where she achieved the surrender of the
orients while reigns flew to dorne in an
unsuccessful mission to make the
martel's bow
meanwhile aegon marched to old town
which was surrendered to him by lord
manfred hightower
upon the advice of the high septon
within the stairs sept the high septon
declared aegon to be the king of the
andals
the rhoynar and the first men lord of
the seven kingdoms and protector of the
realm
aegon chose to make his seed king's
landing a new settlement growing around
the aegon fort
he took the swords of his defeated
enemies forging them into the iron
throne
aegon also began what would become known
as the small council
as well as that of the hand of the king
with lord doris baratheon becoming his
first hand
aegon's first established law was the
king's peace which forbids conflict in
the realm
without the leave of the armed round
aegon treated the defeated lords with
respect
and allowed each region to retain its
own laws and customs
aegon often traveled around with six
maesters who educated him on each
region's local customs and history
in 2ac aegon turned his attention to the
iron islands
where the ironborn had been fighting for
two years over the kingship
aegon landed on great back with valerian
and the war fleet
to deal with the contenders egan
personally cut down quaran walmart with
blackfyre
while the priest's king lotus walked
into the sea drowning himself
the other contenders quickly bent the
knee aegon allowed the ironborn to name
their own lord paramount
for which the ironborn chose to become
greyjoy as lord of the iron islands
despite a highly successful reign aegon
did face considerable problems
and none were as difficult to deal with
as the first dornish war
in 3ac aegon turned his attention back
on dorne
the only kingdom remaining unconquered
he first decided to try and bring dorne
under the rule of the iron throne
through diplomacy
after a year of negotiations and no
progress to show for it all though
aegon decided to take dorne by force of
arms
in 4ac aegon launched a new invasion
continuing the wars of conquest
although initially the conquest of
dornes seemed to succeed
it unraveled quickly and the first
during shore prolonged and lasted for
nine years
and knew many deaths and tragedies one
of these tragedies was the capture and
mutilation of aegon's friend
and the hand of the king lordoris
baratheon
by the veil of vel following his release
from two years of captivity oris
returned home lacking a
swordhand aegon intent on revenge
released his dragons
and burned the castles of defiant
dornish lords
in 7ac aegon became a father for the
first time
when his younger sister wife rhaenys
gave birth to a son amy's
the greatest law sagan faced was the
death of queen reigning targaryen and
hellholt in 10 ac
when marxists fell from the sky with
rainies upon her back
after a shot from a scorpion took the
dragon in the eye
the war took a different turn after this
aegon's fury and grief had the loss of
his rifles such
that he headed for dorne himself
accompanied by visenya the last two
targaryens reigned fire upon the desert
strongholds
to break the dornish the next two years
were known as the dragon's road
a period when every dornish castle fell
the fury of the dragonriders
the only castle spared was sunspear the
seat of house mortal
in hopes that the dornish would turn
against their liege lords
the strategy failed and dorne remained
unconquered
in 11ac queen vizzenia announced her
pregnancy
and the next year she gave birth to
aegon's second son maegor
memphis says miriam martel died in 13ac
her son prince nymore sued for peace
having grown weary of war he sent his
daughter diriya with the skull of
marxists and a letter with her
took his landing to treat with the
conqueror the peace demanded by dorne
was peace between two sovereign kingdoms
not between a liege and his vessel
although aegon heard her out
against the advice of his advisor such
as zorris and nizenya
he apparently decided to refuse the
request for peace
before he could speak dirian mounted the
iron throne
and placed the letter from her father in
his hand
what was in the letter is unknown but
tagon's hand was so clenched around it
that it started to bleed
he burned the ladder and left on
valerian for dragonstone
the next morning he returned and signed
the peace treaty proposed by the prince
of dorne
recognizing it as a sovereign kingdom
historians suspect that nymore had
revealed to aegon that rhaenys was still
alive
and badly injured from falling off
marxists and that he would end her
suffering if the conqueror agreed to
peace
however i do not believe this to be true
because aegon kept good relations with
princess diria afterward
perhaps his sister survived the fall and
she delivered her to aegon on
dragonstone
he even visited sunspear with his eldest
son prince aeneas in 23ac
to celebrate the 10th anniversary of the
peace between the iron throne and dorne
anyways the conqueror was almost killed
by assassins in the streets of king's
landing
and was only saved by visenya this led
to creation of the kingsguard
but its first members chosen by visenya
to protect her brother husband with
their lives
the remaining 24 years of aegon's reign
were peaceful
so much that the last two decades of his
reign were later called the dragon's
peace
by the maesters of the citadel he spent
much of his time consolidating his power
by traveling throughout the seven
kingdoms
and building his capital at king's
landing in 37 ac on dragonstone
while telling his two eldest grandsons
say gonna miseries the tales of his
conquest at the painted table
aegon died from a stroke at the age of
64. aegon was cremated on dragonstone
and his funeral pyre was set aflame by
vargar
blackfire was burned along with him but
later retrieved from the pyre by magor
this is the story of a legendary ear
mythical figure
aegon to conquer let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below
once again house of the dragon a game of
thrones prequel about house targaryen is
coming in 2022 on hbo
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace